[Applauso]
[Musica]
oggi sono qui per darvi delle buone
notizie dal mondo della scienza e dal
mondo della musica finalmente delle
buone notizie un gruppo di ricercatori
dell'università di tokyo stava studiando
con gli algoritmi più potenti che ci
sono i computer più potenti immaginate
per in un laboratorio di informatica
come risolvere i problemi del traffico
trovare delle soluzioni molto efficienti
che riguardano i problemi del traffico
di tokyo poi a un certo punto si sono
spostate su una un organismo
unicellulare una ne va un alga
mucillaginosa per la su cui ci vogliamo
sul cemento della città e hanno scoperto
che quest'alga questa aneva unicellulare
una sola cellula aveva un intelligenza
di gran lunga superiore
nell'organizzarsi nel trovare le
postazioni dei nutrienti quindi l'ha
portata in laboratorio e ha spostato
l'attenzione sulla natura su questo
organismo unicellulare qualcosa di molto
simile avviene nel nostro corpo durante
il processo di angiogenesi quindi quando
formiamo i nostri vasi sanguini quando
siamo nella pancia della nostra mamma
ancora che dobbiamo formare il nostro
corpo creare quelle forme un processo di
morfogenesi molto interessante dal punto
di vista biologico alla morfogenesi la
creazione delle forme del nostro corpo e
anche lì ci sono delle manine che escono
dalle cellule del nostro corpo
immaginate il nostro corpo come una
comunità di 50.000 miliardi di cellule
di organismi viventi alcuni ds appunto
quelli che formano i vasi sanguini
estroflettono delle piccole manine che
si chiamano filo cody e con un
meccanismo che si chiama active
perception vanno a toccare i tessuti
vicino le cellule vicine con dei valori
di
cooperazione di
ascolto proprio una percezione attiva di
organizzazioni che vi consentono un
momento per momento di prendere delle
decisioni sono proprio nelle creature in
grado le nostre cellule di prendere in
modo autonomo con un intelligenza di
milioni di anni delle decisioni la
direzione da shader quindi capite
all'interno della biologia all'interno
della nostra vita la biologia e la
scienza della vita quanto siano
importanti i nostri valori più profondi
che sono di cooperazione di cercare
nelle persone diverse da noi delle
cellule diverse da noi cellule del
sangue che coprono con cellule dell'osso
con cellule della pelle per creare
questa morfogenesi questa
differenziazione cellulare che crea la
meraviglia del nostro corpo questa è la
natura la nostra natura più profonda e
la musica cosa c'entra c'entra perché
all'interno delle nostre cellule ci sono
dei tessuti ci sono delle trame
rischiavano citoscheletro create dai
microtubuli che sono come e corda
all'interno del pianoforte che fanno sì
che ogni nostra cellula è uno strumento
musicale
siamo pieni di strumenti musicali che
comunicano tra di loro non soltanto
attraverso la chimica ma anche
attraverso la luce e il suono il
professor carlo ventura studia con dei
microfoni con una punta atomica ascolta
il suolo di una cellula sana diversa da
una cellula malata diverso da una
cellula morte all'interno del nostro
corpo la vita e la morte continuamente
creano dei cicli meravigliose per far sì
che possiamo rigenerare il nostro corpo
ogni giorno della nostra vita sentite
come siamo nati per stare bene per stare
per essere ingratitudine potremmo
chiudere gli occhi per metà della nostra
giornata e ringraziare per avere un
corpo così meraviglioso che ci crea in
ogni istante della nostra vita
equilibrio salute gioia di vivere
e questi valori che mettono insieme la
biologia e la musica con questi valori
vorrei adesso fare un esperimento con
voi perché la creatività che c'è lena la
natura oltre alla raffinatezza fa sì che
in ogni secondo della nostra vita in
ogni secondo sulla terra nascono cinque
bambini nuovi e quindi la natura si deve
inventare cinque nuovi libretti
d'istruzione cinque nuovi dna che
scendono sulla terra diversi da tutti
quelli che sono scesi sulla terra fino a
destra e deve inventarsi immaginate
cinque nuove forme del viso per esempio
lo immaginate cinque nuove forme in ogni
secondo cinque nuove forme del corpo
cinque nuove vite pensate la creatività
della natura
e allora adesso vorrei fare questo
esperimento sulla creare attività con
voi in cui ci uniremo tutti insieme in
un organismo che mi immagino l'umanità
un organismo come quello del nostro
corpo in cui siamo celluline tutte
diverse tra di noi ma possiamo tutti
insieme formare una sinfonia di vita
suonerà un brano che ho composto l'anno
scorso quando uno dei miei punti di
riferimenti più importanti il maestro
ezio bosso ha lasciato il corpo vi
ricordate il 15 di maggio
mi sono seduto davanti al pianoforte non
proprio sul seggiolino sul vialetto che
guarda pianoforte soltanto a guardare il
pianoforte per ricordarmi di lui
e poi come fossi stato spinto sul
seggiolino a suonare qualcosa mi
sembrava che ci fosse anche 2 di lucia
questa non è biologia è stata una
sensazione mi ha aiutato a comporre
questo brano che nuovo che voglio
portare oggi per voi che si intitola
proprio insieme e cosa vorrei che
facessimo insieme noi qui nel teatro
anche decine di migliaia di persone che
guarderanno poi questo video facciamolo
tutti insieme proviamo a sintonizzarci
con la musica ascoltare la musica in
modo diverso da come siamo abituati con
questo tipo di accordatura a 432 hearts
ad ascoltare gli spazi tra le note in
quegli spazi vibrano le nostre cellule
che ascoltano un messaggio e risuonano
con quel messaggio e proviamo a mandare
un nuovo messaggio a tutta l'umanità che
in questo momento sta con tutta la sua
creatività creando il nuovo volto
immaginate il nuovo volto dell'umanità
un voto che sorride un volto nuovo volto
di rinascita un volto di gratitudine un
volto che rispecchia perfettamente tutti
i valori di ognuna delle nostre cellule
che compongono in questo momento il
nostro corpo
[Musica]
[Applauso]